дванадцять, плюс п'ять
плюс десять
Валерія Моісеєва сама веде підрахунок,
щоб знати, на скільки днів має право поїхати до ЄС
за правилами безвізового режиму.
Усього сорок шість днів.
По безвізу українці можуть перебувати у країнах Шенгену
не більше 90-та днів протягом періоду в 180 днів.
Безвізовий режим діє вже півроку
і загроза депортації або заборони на в'їзд
за порушення цього правила стає реальністю
для всіх власників біометричних паспортів.
Тож Валерія завела собі спеціальний календар
тільки для безвізу - де відзначає, скільки днів вже провела в ЄС.
Це моя особисто відповідальність.
Якщо я порушу цей режим, режим перебування в Шенген-зоні,
то напевно, я якийсь час не зможу подорожувати
і відвідувати ті міста й країни, які я собі запланувала.
Спеціально для тих, хто не бажає власноруч рахувати
або сумнівається, чи не перевищив цю норму,
на сайті Єврокомісії можна знайти так званий
"шенгенський калькулятор".
Внесіть дату бажаного приїзду до Шенгенської зони,
а також дати своїх останніх поїздок
і програма залюбки підрахує,
скільки вам залишилося з нинішнього ста вісімдесятиденного періоду.
Також є калькулятор і російською мовою.
Отриманий результат можна роздрукувати
та показувати прикордонникам
як, власне, й особисті підрахунки.
Проте українцям недовго доведеться так мучитись.
Вже 2020-го року в ЄС
запрацює нова система реєстрації
в'їзду та виїзду іноземних громадян.
І замість штампів та перевірок прикордонників
системи сама рахуватиме дозволений період перебування у Шенгені.